it's the late 90s and an air canada
flight experiences severe malfunctions
while traveling from london to vancouver
the pilots are unable to do anything and
the plane crashes into the woods of
northern alberta
the crash was devastating only 10 of the
nearly 300 people on board are alive
and even though they survived the
initial disaster their battle for life
has only just begun
it's late autumn in northern canada and
there's no telling when help will arrive
if at all if the survivors want to make
it through the night
they need to find shelter and fast
as they trudge through the freezing
woods the group finds a path that looks
like it might lead them to civilization
after all if there was a path in the
woods that meant they were probably in a
national
park and if they were in a national park
there had to be a ranger station around
somewhere where they could warm up and
call for help
they didn't have many other options so
they followed the path which
opened up to a clearing but instead of
finding a ranger station or campground
they found something none of them could
have expected it was a pond
but there was something off about it as
they got closer
they saw that this strange pond wasn't
filled with water
but blood the survivors were horrified
that couldn't really be blood
could it it must have been a weird algae
or chemical reaction
but one member of the group a man named
thomas dean who had been on his way back
to his hometown of prince george british
columbia
thought there was something strangely
familiar about this
he remembered being a boy and going to
visit family in alberta
and hearing an urban legend from the
older local kids
according to the stories somewhere out
in the wilderness
in the northern part of the province
there was a pond full of human blood
and what made it even worse was that
some said the pond was a gateway
to hell the scp foundation was also
aware of this legend
and had been trying to pinpoint the
exact source of it for decades prior
to the air canada crash they would
finally receive definite confirmation of
the blood pond when foundation personnel
intercepted a radio transmission from a
ranger station located within the wood
buffalo national park
it was the survivors of the crash who
had managed to make it through the night
and they were about to be escorted out
of the park by rangers
the foundation mobilized quickly to
cordon off the pond as at the time they
were unsure of what potentially harmful
properties the pond might have had
they set up watch station epsilon 38 and
put staff on guard to deter travelers
from the area
the pond was given the designation of
scp-354
and classed as euclid foundation
scientists made a number of interesting
discoveries about scp-350
when they collected samples for testing
first the pawn was not
in fact full of blood merely an
inorganic liquid that closely resembles
blood in color and consistency
second and even stranger than the red
liquid is that the pond doesn't seem to
have any definite banks or a bottom
instead the liquid in the pond increases
in density as the radius away from the
center increases
the liquid congeals at the edges
becoming more solid
and blending into the surrounding soil
it also becomes
thicker as one descends deeper into the
pool and a bottom of the pond has not
yet been reached
if it even exists initially the
foundation found no signs of life within
the blood pond
but that would all change at 203 pm on
the day following the opening of watch
station epsilon 38
when the science team noticed an unusual
level of activity on the pond's surface
security footage feeds showed a shape
rising out of the pond
followed by a deafening shriek after
that the feed was cut and foundation
lost all communication with watch
station epsilon 38
fearing the worst a mobile task force
was dispatched to the location
when they got there all personnel at the
watch station had been killed by what
could only be described as a gigantic
bat
the task force was able to neutralize
the entity and as soon as they could
the foundation moved in to increase
security around the scp
creating area 354 and installing a
permanent security detail
after this point the pawn started to
regularly spit out a variety of
monstrous entities
almost as if it was reacting to the scp
foundation's increased security measures
after scp-354-1 the giant back
came scp-354 354-2 was an echidna-like
monster the size of a bear
that was virtually bulletproof but
unable to escape area 3-5-4
the foundation neutralized this anomaly
with napalm
scp-354-3 was a floating black sphere
capable of firing deadly beams of
concentrated energy
the area's head scientist was able to
hit it with a sledgehammer
causing the sphere to malfunction and
self-destruct before it was able to
escape
the area the foundation wasn't as lucky
with scp-354-4
this creature was a reptilian humanoid
that stood roughly 15 feet tall
and was unable to be put down with
gunfire this was the first creature from
the pond to successfully escape
containment
and was only able to be neutralized when
the foundation sent in mobile task force
omega-7
also known as pandora's box the data on
pond incursions is partially corrupted
so a complete list of creatures is not
available but some of the other monsters
that came out of the blood pond include
a killer robot
a set of gigantic tentacles that drag
several d-class personnel into the pond
a pair of panther-like creatures one
made of ice and the other of magma
that ignored foundation staff and
instead fought each other
and one seemingly normal human man who
was executed as soon as he emerged from
the pond
tests on his body revealed that he was
in fact totally normal
and would have posed no threat these
anomalies came out of the pond at fairly
regular intervals for several months
before the pond went silent for an
unprecedented 22 months
the head scientists at the time noted i
suspect this means one of two things
either the red pool has died or powered
down or whatever the correct term for it
is
or is charging up for something big to
come through
o5 believes the former is the most
likely explanation
and has recalled 30 of our total
personnel and cut 25
of our funding well i can only hope that
they are correct
if the latter situation is true we're
soon to face some terrible monstrosity
and we won't have anywhere near the
force necessary to deal with it
i worry for all of our safety his words
would prove eerily prophetic following
the events of exploratory mission 354
alpha the foundation's research and
development team built a specialized
craft to explore the pond
because of the strange properties of the
pond's density the craft was essentially
made to be both a submarine
for parts of the pond where the contents
were liquid and a drill
for when the liquid congealed into a
semi-solid towards the bottom
the exploration team consisted of agent
swanson agent turquoise
agent 86 dr j mcarthur chris simmons
leroy tucker and a pilot named martin
with the team assembled
the ship was sent down into the pond
nothing eventful happened for the first
two days of the mission
but at 4 30 a.m on the third day gravity
suddenly reversed for the crew of the
ship this seemed to indicate that they
were approaching the halfway point
though what would be on the other side
nobody could say
on the fourth day the ship surfaced
proving definitely that the pond was in
fact some sort of portal
the crew looked out of the portholes to
see the darkness of night above them
while sensors outside the ship detected
nothing harmful in the atmosphere around
them
the crew were wary of exiting the craft
the other side of the pond was nothing
like the world the crew
knew for one thing the night lasted for
28 hours before dawn came
and when the sun finally rose it was
much larger and redder
than the earth's sun under the light of
the strange red star
the crew could see that the pond on this
side was massive
compared to what they've come into more
like a large lake
surrounding the lake was sand and rocks
that were covered in a kind of moss that
disappeared under sunlight and re-grew
during the night the team left the ship
and started to explore
during their time in this strange world
they found that the day lasted just a
few hours shorter than the night
meaning that whatever planet they were
on had a roughly 43-hour long rotation
as opposed to our own planets 24.
the team found a number of anomalous
elements on their expedition
including razor-sharp grass that can
puncture skin and streams of liquid
carbon dioxide
they heard some loud roars in the
distance once or twice but other than
that
the planet was eerily silent with
seemingly no animal life
and not even wind when it rained the
soil remained dry
and based on that the scientists
theorized the plants in this world were
more efficient at absorbing moisture
on the 25th day the team ran into a huge
metal wall that appeared to be
artificially constructed
luckily leroy tucker a quick thinking
researcher
was able to rig a blow torch from
camping supplies and melt a hole through
the metal
on the other side there was finally wind
and
odd black grass that's the extent of
what is known about the other side of
the wall
because the expedition logs are heavily
corrupted after that point
but we know that whatever was in there
wasn't good because the team never
returned
strangely there's no record of any names
mentioned in the ship's log
almost as if being killed on the other
side completely erased them from history
no other expeditions into the pond were
launched after that
on an undisclosed date a year following
the discovery of the blood pond and
construction of area 354
the site was completely evacuated and
power was cut to the area
mobile task force data 12 was dispatched
to investigate the cause of the
evacuation
but before contact could be established
the area's on-site nuclear warhead was
detonated
completely destroying the site mtf theta
12 was then attacked by a convoy made up
of d-class and other low-ranking staff
who had evacuated area 3-5-4
it was apparent that there had been some
kind of mutiny within the site
and that a dissolution of the chain of
command had led to its evacuation and
destruction
the convoy totally annihilated mtf theta
12
and no further contact with the former
personnel of area 354
has been made since following the site's
detonation
a new site was constructed called simply
the red pool
containment site unlike the previous
facility which focused on research
and neutralization the new site is
entirely concerned with containment
the shift in directive came as a
response to the pawn's apparent reactive
nature
each creature that emerged from the pond
seemed to be in retaliation to the
foundation's
actions and it was theorized by some
that the mutiny at area 354 was
triggered by some kind of psychic attack
from the pond itself
an interview in the scp file on 354
reveals that there was one more
disastrous attempt to control and
understand the blood pond according to
an interview with a foundation
agent the head doctor proposed a scheme
to drain the blood pond using a system
of pumps and hoses
all non-essential personnel were
evacuated in case of emergency
leaving only the pump technicians
d-class personnel
and a few agents for security however as
soon as the pump was scheduled to be
turned on
everyone at the side experienced a mass
dissociative episode
the agent described the feeling they all
experienced as like being
in a dream and suddenly realizing that
you're asleep
he said everything stopped being real it
was like we had to escape right now
when asked what happened when the pump
was turned on he simply explained that
it wouldn't let them
this interview confirmed the theory that
the pond is not only capable of
releasing monsters out into our world
but also that it's capable of powerful
but much more subtle
psychological attacks this suggests a
chilling possibility
that the pond isn't just blindly
reacting to being attacked
but it's fully sentient and the actions
of the scp foundation have only served
to annoy it
and worst studies of the pons banks have
proved evidence that the area of
congealed liquid around the perimeter of
the pond has been steadily expanding
that's right the pond is getting bigger
the last thing the foundation agent
stationed at the site said before being
dragged out of the interview and sedated
was
it gets bigger and stronger every day
and now
we've made it angry now go check out
scp-087 the stairwell
and scp-096 the shy guy for more classic
foundation foes